as we've been talking about sort of more
and more over the last couple of weeks
presidential impeachment proceedings
have to be started by a member of the
House of Representatives and on
Wednesday in the wake of Donald Trump's
firing of FBI director James Comey and
the revelation that Trump asked Comey to
stop investigating Michael Flynn
Democratic Representative Al Green from
Texas became the first congressman to
officially request Donald Trump's
impeachment on the floor of the House of
Representatives here he is doing it I
rise today mr. speaker to call for the
impeachment of the President of the
United States of America for obstruction
of justice I do not do this for
political purposes mr. speaker now I do
this because I believe in the great
ideals that this country stands for
liberty and justice for all in response
congressman greens office started
receiving racist hateful and threatening
voicemails including threats of lynching
Al Green happens to the African American
one caller said hey Al Green we've got
an impeachment for you it's going to be
yours it's actually going to give you a
short trial before we hang your n-word
ass another voicemail left for Al Green
you ain't gonna impeach nobody you
effing n-word try it and we'll lynch all
of you effing n-words you'll be hanging
from a tree I didn't see anybody calling
for the impeachment of your n-word Obama
when he was born in Kenya he's not even
an American so f you n-word the caller
there also happens to be wrong there
were endless numbers of people calling
for Obama's impeachment even though
Obama didn't actually do anything that
remotely warranted it and there were
more voice motor voicemails these are
not just acts of racial hatred these are
death threats to an American congressman
and I hope they're being taken seriously
by the investigating authorities yeah
unfortunately there's a group of people
who will defend Donald Trump no matter
what and there's also a group of people
who will make these racist remarks and
make threats and sometimes there's some
overlap there luckily
Al Green isn't letting this get to him I
hope not I hope it is not and it seems
unlikely that these callers conspired
together to make these calls these are
multiple people who said Oh someone's
calling for the impeachment of Trump I'm
going to call and say racist things to
him because he's black I don't even
think it's because he represents a
district in Texas these calls could have
come from anywhere in the United States
I'm really surprised Pat that this was
the reaction of some Trump supporters to
a black man calling me it's calling for
the impeachment of a right-wing hero
president like Donald Trump obviously
I'm kidding around that's the saddest
thing which is that who's surprised by
this who is surprised given how the
entire primary and general election went
with Trump supporters and rallies and
the rise of the outright this is exactly
what I expected to happen when a black
congressman called for Trump's
impeachment he's the only congressman
thus far who is calling for the
impeachment of Donald Trump so of course
it's going to be some political backlash
that's another thing to hear this from
constituents and maybe people who aren't
in your concision and after Al Green
played these voicemail recordings at a
town Town Hall he said quote we are not
going to be intimidated we are not going
to allow this to cause us to deviate
from what we believe to be the right
thing to do Democrats and Republicans
conservatives and liberals there are
differences right when Republicans
called for impeaching Obama for no
reason they were not getting race and
identity based violent threats on their
voicemails in these numbers period even
though again it was completely
unwarranted and race arguably played at
least some part in their desire to see
President Obama impeached if you want to
try to sort of work as a counterbalance
you can call congressman greens office
to thank him for his service if you want
at 2:02 two two five seven five zero
eight today's episode of the David
Pakman show is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker
recently did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wear
in contact lenses I started with the
free at-home trial they send you five
pairs of glasses you see which one do
you like you send them back and
whichever one you pick they will put
your prescription in - I like this
because I can actually show the glasses
to other people and not have to just
decide on the spot like in an eyeglass
store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS